now that doesn't mean that anything goes
Free Speech has its limits even in
America with its Fable First Amendment
there are limits you can't famously run
into a theater in America and shout fire
and create a stampede where people might
die so there are limits to free speech
all around the world
but my guest tonight
well he tests free speech to I would
argue it's breaking point his name is
Alex Jones he's a hugely influential to
many people a very dangerous conspiracy
theorist who's made himself hugely Rich
peddling a lot of lies this is what
happened when we met last debating gun
laws a decade ago on CNN
how many gun murders were there in
Britain how many great white sharks how
many kill people every year but they're
scared to swim and I'm here to tell you
1776 will commence again if you try to
take our Firearms but you've got hordes
of people burning down cities and
beating old women's Brains out every day
let's try again how many gun murders
were there oh gonna ban your Festival in
Britain last year uh how many uh
chimpanzees can dance on the head of a
pin
well I've not spoken to Alex Jones in an
interview format uh since that day uh he
is now uh I would say comfortably the
world's most notorious conspiracy
theorist as I say I defend everybody's
right to an honestly held opinion I
defend everyone's right to use words of
their choice but it doesn't mean they're
not accountable for those words uh and I
don't think Alex Jones necessarily
trades in honestly held opinions but
we'll come to that when I talk to him
very few tragedies have ever moved me
the way that Sandy Hook did I was on air
as CNN at the time of that story broke
20 children aged between six and seven
were murdered by lunatic with a
semi-automatic rifle Alex Jones told his
many followers within a few hours it was
all a hoax a government hoax a deep
State plot to justify seizing guns he
said that the grieving families were
actors
the general public doesn't know the
school was actually closed the year
before they don't know they've shielded
all demolished the building they don't
know that uh they had the kids going in
circles in and out of the building as a
photo op blue screen green screens but
it took me about a year with Sandy Hook
to come to grips with the fact that the
whole thing was fake
even I couldn't believe it I knew they
jumped on it used the crisis hyped it up
but then I did deep research and my gosh
it just pretty much didn't happen
but it did happen those children did get
murdered
they were riddled with Bullets by an
AR-15 semi-automatic rifle I can't even
imagine as a father of four kids what
that site must have looked like those
parents had to see their children
riddled with bullets
and then they had to put up with years
of harassment and threats and
disgraceful incidents
because Alex Jones fueled a conspiracy
theory almost immediately that the whole
thing was fake and that these parents
who were grieving for their dead
children that they were actors
I have made my views clear about that
but I also think that it's right that I
should interview him tonight uh he
wanted to come on and talk to me and to
explain what's gone down here and where
he's found himself which is facing a 1.5
billion dollar payout to the families in
various lawsuits that they took and I do
believe that people should be allowed to
express themselves as long as they're
held to account and they're challenged
on that and that's what we're going to
do tonight with Alex Jones so my guest
tonight is Alex Jones he's over in Texas
and America Alex uh good evening to you
Pierce it's good to be here with you
after 10 years and the biggest news
event on CNN in 2013 so the circle is
now complete but you just spent eight
minutes
saying a lot of things that were true a
lot of things that weren't true so I'd
like to address that right now if I can
when I came on your show months and
months after Sandy Hook
in the scene in studios in New York I
never said it didn't happen I never sent
people their houses when the internet
went totally viral in the next year
questioning it with anomalies I did
Cover 23 minutes that's what they
introduced in court over the next few
years a few times we're talking five six
shows
what the internet was questioning on my
call-in radio show with a document cam
on air but I did not build my career off
Sandy Hook I barely not even one tenth
of one percent
covered it and so to say that I sent
people to harass families or I didn't
say that on the graves I don't say that
I didn't say you sent me you wanted to
do anything I want to have an Alex I
want to want to have a race let me just
say I want to have a reasonable
conversation I want to get into the
screaming match that descended into last
time I think that's futile of everyone
watching you are now a very Infamous
person around the world you know that a
lot of people know about you what
they've read most of it negative this is
your chance to explain what's happened
and to if you want to uh Express remorse
for things that you've got wrong and
done wrong you find yourself in a very
bad place right now you're facing paying
out potentially 1.5 billion dollars to
these families you've said that you
don't have that money you can't pay that
money so far you haven't paid any of the
money uh how do you feel first of all
about the fact that you've faced this
gigantic
uh well victory for the families and
defeat for you
okay so you did eight minutes and 45
seconds attacking me I got 30 seconds I
will answer your question a moment but I
want to get something completely
straight I came on your show months and
months and months and months after it
happened I blamed the serotonin reuptake
Inhibitors the antidepressants I blame
the mother getting him the gun on your
show so the claim that I first
questioned Sandy Hook or I first did it
was a bunch of professors and a bunch of
media people became a huge story I
looked at it and said yeah we've seen
wmds in Iraq we've seen operation
Northwoods we see Justin smallett later
we see now admitted the Twitter files
that they had thousands of fake doctors
online saying the shot was safe and
effective and protected you something
you've come out and said was wrong and
was a lie so I always questioned every
major event but I did not make my bones
on Sandy Hook I barely covered it on
your show months and months and months
after it happened
long after listen I don't you may well
categorize this as a very small small
part of your career unfortunately for
you it's now become this gigantic part
of your career because of the nature of
this payouts I'm like that's totally
true specifically to ask you what did
you feel about the size of the payout
you've been ordered to pay and the fact
that you suffered one of the biggest
losses of any lawsuit of that nature in
modern history
well I mean it's not one of the biggest
it's the biggest and uh so so if you
actually want the inside baseball to
know what actually went on I'm really
happy to tell you I'm more interested in
addicts and how you you built this
Empire and I'm going to come to how you
built it in a moment you built this
Empire as a very uh provocative many
would argue they found you very
entertaining as well high energy uh you
know Mischief making shock jock for want
of a better phrase who went on the
airwaves and said a lot of very
controversial things and built up a very
big following and made a vast amount of
money doing it
um I mean you wouldn't dispute any of
that right that's not attacking you
that's just a statement of fact so
listen but I'm happy to come on but
you've had 90 of the talk time
I just want you to answer
what you want about I understand again I
don't want to have a confrontational
interview I simply want to ask you
as I say you've built this big Empire
and now the entire Empire has been
imperiled by losing this lawsuit and you
wouldn't dispute that no
no I had more than 15 offers right now
on huge networks if if my system goes
under let me just explain something to
you and let's talk facts okay here's a
timeline of 10 and a half years since or
10 years two months in Sandy Hook
it happens the first year I don't think
it's staged it becomes a huge internet
thing that it's staged I have a few
debates I have a few guests on I covered
I said yeah it could be staged so much
stuff is staged then I go two plus years
2015 into 16 never discussing it this
all came out in the lawsuit
and then they run against Trump Hillary
runs 30 million dollars of TV ads
showing edited clips of me saying
synthetic event never happened and then
Trump still wins and we now learned
after the lawsuits they hired a
high-powered New York Think Tank
PR firm to then make it a huge story
tens of thousands of Articles thousands
of newscasts about me in 2016-17 about
San Diego I go whoa those anomalies I
heard from those professors and people
were wrong I think it happened nobody
sued me no one Joe Rogan apologized do a
whole apology to her because I wasn't
sophisticated back then I'm like yeah I
think it happened I barely covered it
then they sue me once I apologize they
have a judge in Texas in Austin this is
liberal in San Francisco and a
Connecticut
sue me then I give them all my text all
my documents which they show in court
but say I gave them no documents they
default me first time in modern U.S
history I'm found guilty by judges and
juries then have hearings on how guilty
I am that they have a false Financial
expert get up and say I'm worth 400
million dollars
a time they did that six months ago in
that hearing in Texas and that kangaroo
operation I had like three million
dollars in the bank what do you say okay
all right let me let me see hold on you
can't just keep talking Alex let me just
explain to you what I think oh God
forbid I get a third of the time you get
well you know what it's my show it's the
way it works on your show again 90 of
the time on your show if I was a guest
you don't want to uh I'm just telling
you I just want to have no one have a
real discussion let's have a normal
debate I want to play you a clip this is
a clip of one of the parents from Sandy
Hook because you've talked about this at
length now Nicole Hockley and I want to
talk after this clip I want you to just
listen to what she had to say to me
recently on the show
he did his first broadcast saying that
he thought this was a false flag
when I was still in the firehouse and I
didn't even know if my child was alive
or dead yet he started off within two
and a half hours of the shooting and has
kept putting out video after video for
year after year after year and calling
us all crisis actors calling our
children you know either that they were
never they were never killed or they
were never alive in the first place
that were traders that were were
treasonous and that were government
chills it's been very difficult it's
been easy to turn off some of it but
some of these people have been
incredibly dangerous and when he says
when he when he Stokes this anger in his
base this fear and then incites them to
action by saying you know we need to
investigate this you need to look into
this more they come at us so part of
it's just social media comments which
can be damaging it's defaming it's
hurting your reputation people I don't
know if I'm walking around who thinks
I'm real and who thinks I'm an actress
it's it's damaging to my son's memory in
terms of his life his short six-year-old
life it's damaging to my surviving son
because I don't know what he's going to
deal with going forward but it's also
scared The Living Daylights out of me I
sleep with weapons by my bedside I've
received death threats I've received
harassing calls and mail I've had people
send me pictures of dead children
because they say as a crisis actor you
have no idea what a dead child looks
like so let me send you this picture so
you can see it this is stuff that has
really not only just been distressing
it's disturbing and in terms of security
you know I'm just a mom I'm just trying
to look after my surviving Son run my
organization and make some good in the
world I didn't choose to be part of this
Alex Jones chose to tell lies
knowing that they were lies and
continuing to Harbor that lie and make
it happen for his own prophet
what's your reaction to to that woman
who lost her son Dylan at Sandy Hook
total garbage never said her name only
person's name I said was Robbie Parker
30 something million views on YouTube he
was laughing everything suddenly started
your response your response to that
woman's incredibly powerful you're gonna
give me five seconds
this is well I guess I can't do this
interview people have to go to
infowars.com later and I'll respond to
you you're not letting me talk I never
said her name under Connecticut and
Texas law you can't sue somebody for
defamation if you never said their name
I didn't do any of those things I was on
your show months and months after it
happened and said it happened and said
it was Prozac I looked at both of the
views and they clipped that out to
attach themselves to me on air I never
talked about that woman I didn't even
know who she was I said it was a husband
you said it was a hoax you said it was
funny dollar bill he said the entire
thing is a giant hoax
the fake Bin Laden raid people just know
there's a lot of fraud going on you've
got here's what I'm gonna say to you
pierce wait a second here let me tell
you five seconds you sent me a list of
topics let me finish you sent me a list
of topics I said I'd come on and one of
them is Sandy Hook I'm on for an hour
let's talk about the damos group yes
let's talk about the words let's talk
talk about the vaccines then are we
going to talk about other topics because
they're attacked they live off me I
didn't make money off
73 million dollars from remedy they live
off Sandy Hook I don't okay here's what
I would say to you maybe one of the
reasons that they have a problem with
you and what you did is that you were
saying on there things like you've got
parents laughing ha ha ha then they walk
over to the camera and go boo hoo hoo
and not just one but a bunch of parents
doing this and then photos of kids that
are still alive they say dead I mean
they think we're so dumb these were
parents I told you
an unbelievable trauma
yeah listen and Madeleine Albright
Secretary of State under Clinton was
asked by Leslie stall in 60 minutes that
Clinton tripled sanctions on Iraq to
kill two million people 500 000 children
she said it was a good thing to do she'd
do it again I didn't kill 500 000
children I question all these events
because many of them are provocaturated
I understand that but I also understand
the immediate the overall the kids dying
from The Poisoned shots
the problem is if I deserve to die for
questioning a mass shooting then what
happens to the big companies that sold
these poison shots that weren't approved
and weren't safe here's my question
I'm the worst guy in the world so Pierce
hold on hold on I'm the worst guy in the
world right I didn't say that
I listen I told them in a deposition
that back when this went on and I
started questioning it like nine years
ago about a year after
but I said false flag I believe they may
have protected him they may have known
it was coming like Uvaldi 75 minutes the
police stood down I believe that was a
real shooter real kids died uh in
Florida at Parkland there was a stand
down why the police chief said well he
thought he'd already killed all the kids
so he didn't want more death that was in
the news that was the Dallas Morning
News yesterday I'm questioning Parkland
saying did they let it happen that's a
false flag to say a false flag doesn't
mean the parents are fake I apologized
on Joe Rogan before I was sued I
apologized on dozens of shows when they
brought this up in 2016. here's my
question here's my question then they
went on the news and said I was
currently sending people their houses
where is the video of me saying go to
their houses where is the video be
pissing on their graves it's not true
they're raising money on my name Alex
let me let me respond I want to just try
and get inside your head for a moment
and see whether you have ever fully
comprehended
scale of what happened to these families
because as things stand I believe 20
percent of Americans one in five believe
that mass shootings like Sandy Hook are
staged a lot of that is down to somebody
like you with your huge following which
you built up consistently suggesting
their stage including Sandy Hook this is
what happened to some of the families
okay
Erica Lafferty whose mother was killed
has had to move five times since the
shooting and avoids going to the grocery
store because people tell us
any evidence
the judges found me guilty that's
illegal I know let me just finish she
said it got scary and more graphic
things would be mailed to her house that
were threats of rape
Jennifer Hensel and Jeremy Rickman
parents of six-year-old aviel who was
killed set up a foundation for their
daughter soon after email addresses
attached to the foundation by black
lives matter let me finish we're flooded
with messages saying Advil didn't exist
the Hensel and others were actors and
questioned why money was being raised
from a fake shooting in 2019 Jeremy
Rickman advil's father killed himself
friends called Hensel his wife Jennifer
to tell her people were at the cemetery
where Advia was buried looking for
evidence that her husband had actually
died
David wheeler the father of six-year-old
Ben Wheeler who died at Sandy Hook
detailed two instances in which people
actually showed up at his home demanding
to see Ben insisting he was alive he
said people also pointed to a student
film he made in college as proof he was
a crisis actor Robbie and Alyssa Parker
and you did mention Robbie Parker who I
interviewed many times and felt a deep
Affinity with and you said he was
laughing after his his uh
but she said that his wife said that the
vicious comments in the memorial
Facebook page honoring his daughter was
so terrifying she couldn't remember much
of her daughter's funeral
Mark banston the lawyer representation
you said one of your topics was Sandy
Hook here's the deal they know they
showed no proof of that in court the
judge didn't let me defend myself okay
you don't you just want to sit here and
talk about Santa Claus
I'm simply my question is simply this
when you hear about the impact on these
poor families whose children age six
were blown to pieces in a school when
you hear about the impact do you have
any real regret or remorse about fueling
Adam this idea
let me talk at all Adam Lanza killed
those children not me a Democratic party
PR firm looked at Trump looked at me in
2007 it wasn't my question brought up
Sandy Hook that wasn't my question
explain to you again I'm gonna say again
the media took what I said out of
context they didn't years later
magnified it let me finish to make a
political hit point on me and on Trump
and they blew it all up and then said I
was doing it they have no proof ever
Sydney by their houses I didn't I a few
times questioned it on air I became
Super Famous I said it was a hoax to me
they've raised hundreds of millions in
in donations 73 million from Remington
now they're coming after the first
amendment it's insane and I told you I'd
come on and briefly talk about Sandy
Hook you sent a whole list of topics now
I want you to be true to your word and
not a deceptive person peers we have
spent 24 minutes on Sandy Hook I want to
move on to the Davos group so the
question first before we move on do you
feel like when you hear these when you
hear these accounts of what happened to
these families do you feel a sense of
personal regret and remorse that you're
actually that your actions
a lot of people to think these people
were actors and their kids didn't really
die do you feel genuine animals
you don't let me talk for any awesome
thousand Iraqi children starve to death
oh you know I feel way less no I
legitimately questioned Sandy Hook and I
stand by what I did a hoax you let me
finish attach themselves to me to raise
money and to claim I'm doing things with
them I didn't do to raise money and to
try to take over my life and no I don't
I apologize before they sued me if I
ever hurt anybody's feelings and I'm
supposed to apologize forever and ever
in some communism
I just asked you whether you feel
regrets I asked you whether you feel
regrets and remorse for fueling this
belief that Sandy Hook was staged and
fake that's the only question I asked
you
when you give an apology which I've
given over 150 times you're done with
the apology type in Alex Jones
apologizes for Sandy Hook you'll have it
before they sued me so I'll point you to
that you're so good at all your Clips
but no I'm not going to come back on
your show in 10 years and you'll say do
you now apologize if I sat here and slit
my throat on air it wouldn't be enough
for you I legitimately question Mass
events because of things like operation
Northwoods that call for staging mass
shootings that didn't occur in the
United States look it up ABC news
Operation Northwoods I came on here
Piers to have a real discussion with you
and ask for money
imagine the biggest settlement ever
fentanyl uh settlements for Oxycontin
settlements that have killed millions of
people and this settlement is way bigger
and they say Jones refuses to pay I
don't have five million dollars much
less a billion and a half dollars so
when they say I refuse to pay if I have
three gallons of blood in my body and
they say we want a thousand gallons I
don't have a thousand gallons of blood
we're going to take a little commercial
break Alex we'll come back and we will
talk about other things after the break
well welcome back Alex Jones is still
with me as we'll move on to other things
I looked at the Infowars website tonight
you were leading uh several hours ago
actually on the story which I addressed
at the top of the show which is about
this ludicrous idea that the word field
is racist I'm sure there are a number of
things like that on which we would have
complete agreement but I also found a
piece on your website near the top today
which said the following falsehoods have
far-reaching costs in livelihoods and
lives lack of integrity and conflicts of
interest have led to an unprecedented
institutional false information pandemic
there's nothing that dispels false
narratives better than personal inquiry
and critical thinking so the next time
conflicted institutions cry woeful wolf
or vicious variant or whatever it is we
need to think twice so very strong
worded piece there about the danger of
falsehoods
do you agree with that
well let me ask you a question and we'll
finish up the Sandy Hook thing I wish
that I wasn't misled by some of those
professors and people that thought that
it was staged it was a very small part
of what I did I tried to apologize I
tried to settle I tried to make
restitution and then they misrepresented
when I was in the Texas trial you can
look at this
uh they had uh one of the mothers on who
lost her son and I went on my show that
morning and taped it before I went to
court and I said I think she's real I
think her son died I've seen her
testimony the day before and I'm very
sorry that Adam Lanza did this and then
she went on the stand and said Jones
attacked me and said I'm an actress it's
all fake today and I walked over to her
during the break and I said watch my
show from today your lawyers lied to you
and the next day she came up and cried
and shook my hand
and Scarlett Lewis had said oh my God
it's true I I saw you did say that so
there's a lot of manipulation here look
I didn't do this consciously I think
their children died
but I think you're being manipulated by
groups I wish I never would have said it
we do have to have uh got you know
guidelines I have messed up a lot in my
life Pierce and listen that's what I
said a love-hate relationship with you
and I sent you an audio message
yesterday I watched the intro to your
show and I was like man I wish I was as
good as this guy because I covered the
same stuff today but the way you brought
up them saying the word America is bad
and the way you pointed out that it's
not by itself that it's a cult that
wants to grow language I was like that
guy's a master of really understanding
this attack on our freedom and I wish he
knew that I was a real guy the
difference Alex honestly the difference
between this I would say is this I have
always strived not always successfully
but I've always thrived in my career to
put a premium on accuracy and facts
because I think without that you have
nothing I would argue and this is your
chance to to dispel this notion that
over the years you have deliberately and
systematically used conspiracy theories
which I suspect you know are not true to
fuel interest in a large number of
people who then go and buy your products
which you sell which are a massive part
of your business and have made you
hundreds of millions of dollars and I'm
going to give you some examples
collectively so let me just read them
hold on everybody
I'll give you a chance to respond when I
read them but you know this is some of
the stuff you said on air right in 2017
you had to apologize after promoting the
infamous pizzagate fake story that a
Washington pizza restaurant was the
Locale of a child's sex abuse ring run
by Hillary Clinton and her campaign
chairman after 9 11 you called it an
inside job perpetrated by the US
government you said that chemicals in
the water which are put there by the
government are turning frogs gay in a
gay bomb you said Michelle Obama is a
man in a 12-minute video you analyze
footage of photographs proving that Mrs
Obama has a penis you said that Robert
Muller the former FBI director who
investigated Trump's Russia ties which
turned out to be can we stop can we hold
on it's one of the things
he's obviously not a pedophile and so on
so here's my point Alex hey are you
there you keep flashing up your info you
don't need to promote info we all know
about it listening on the front page
and I can't respond let me ask you the
question I'm about to ask you I read a
piece on Infowars all about the danger
of falsehoods right the cost to
livelihoods and lives the problem with
lack of integrity and the false
information pandemic your website is
promoting that thinking that it's wrong
to have false information but other and
yet the guy behind the website making
all the money is the guy saying all this
stuff which is obviously
you know it's nonsense don't you you're
scared to let me talk your chance to
respond no I don't know it's nonsense
and if you took your time through all
those points you just raised I can back
every one of them there are more than a
thousand university studies from England
to Australia to South Africa to Mexico
to Austin Texas that atrazine is
literally making male frogs gay they
don't want to have sex with female frogs
and their populations are plummeting and
even becoming extinct boom then 911 I
don't think radical Islam doesn't exist
there were criminal elements about in
our government that it came out even in
the year hearings that stood down and
did nothing so you rattle off 9 11 was
not an inside job Michelle Obama is not
a man Robert Mueller is not a
demonologists
these are all ridiculous lies and here's
the point Alex you're not a stupid just
repeat it again
you know these things
let me talk
it was that is a transcript you have
I was playing a clip
of Joan Rivers two months before she
died
with fire exploding out of her mouth in
a surgery
she said Michelle Obama is a [ __ ]
everybody knows that we already have a
gay president
I was quoting what she said and and I I
was questioning what people were saying
That's Joan Rivers now let's move on
what was the other one what was the
other one you were saying robot Muller
is a demonic pedophile
Robert Mueller is definitely okay let's
talk about pizza gate I didn't
regenerate Pizza gate it was in the
Wikileaks documents a whole bunch of
Aleister Crowley Satan you apologize
because you promoted that conspiracy
theory too here's my point Alex I don't
think you really believe any of these
things I think you realized early on in
your life that there was a lot of money
to be made from fueling conspiracy
theories and you have made it right
I said Jeffrey Epstein 13 years ago ran
an island in the Caribbean with
kidnapped children I said the Nexium
cult was branding people five years
before it broke no I had the sources and
I had the guts I lost viewers saying
Sandy Hook might have been staged I lost
some of my reporters that is not true
what you're saying I don't sit there and
think of a story I'm gonna say I've got
too many stories here
and then say Oh I'm going to lie about
this thing I said Jesse smallett despite
the fact I was already sued by Sandy
Hook I said the day after it before
anybody else I said I think it staged I
think at 2 30 in the morning 22 below I
agree Chicago I thought it was something
guys walking around here's my point now
again here's my point to you here's my
here's my question for you believe it
you are a smart enough person
from interviews I've seen of you with
Joe Rogan for three hours you're more
than smart enough to do a show where you
genuinely examine stories like justice
Moller and you ask the right questions
as a journalist would do but I don't
think you are a journalist I know that
you're not saying you're not a trained
journalist but you don't come at it like
a journalist you come at it as a
commercial operator who's made a fortune
from fueling conspiracy theories which
are ludicrous and to a point be
responsible
you had me here let me respond to each
line let me finish
let me finish I'm going to tell you
again I'm gonna tell you again I'm not
against capitalism and the people earn
money normally and actually that's great
if I sell 70 million dollars of food and
supplements and books and films and we
make 20 million dollars off that and I
pay my career and my bandwidth and pay
myself a couple million dollars a year
that is accurate but the idea that I
have billions of dollars and the idea
that I that I did I don't think you've
made millions of dollars I think you've
made several hundred million dollars and
some of the products included very false
claims about diet supplements and
toothpaste which could be used to fight
coronavirus and you were sent to cease
and decisions all I said is is that
silver eye contact kills all viruses
just like sunlight and I said vitamin D3
is an antiviral and vitamin C is and
it's a fact and it also set beers that
the studies they'd already done with
mRNA vaccine showed they didn't protect
you and they erase your immune system
and you've had to apologize
no no just to clarify they do protect
you from coronavirus the difference was
a year into the pandemic it was it
emerged that the initial feeling that if
you had the vaccine you couldn't
transmit it turned out to be wrong but
they didn't be real vaccines
in Nuremberg too you're going to stand
at Nuremberg too oh did you get money
from Big Pharma no I didn't get any of
these other media people we're gonna say
yeah listen the vaccines won did you get
money the value
millions of Lies however let's take a
short break with our final segments
one last question
welcome back to my final segment with
Alex Jones Alex on uh January 6th at the
infamous January the sixth you stood
there writing the crowns up by saying we
declare 1776 against the New World Order
we need to understand under attack we
need to understand Mrs 21st century
Warfare and get on the wall footing and
within several hours that's exactly what
thousands of people did they went down
from hearing you say that and Donald
Trump was saying what he said and they
launched an unprecedented attack on the
capital the very center of Democracy in
America uh do you regret now what you
said at that speech
uh no I don't I'd had rallies with over
a million people a half million people
before that it's an information War
infowars.com we're in an information War
we were there to have a 10-day
investigation of the Constitution the
Democrats have done it before just a few
years before to look at what was
happening we were there peaceful and
then peers I tried to stop people and
did keep thousands from going into the
Capitol and I've been cleared in the
January 6th look at the Warriors just to
be clear do you denounce those who use
violence that day yes I denounced rayups
telling uh the Congressional committee
that he orchestrated the attack and I
tried to stop the provocateurs uh in
that operation from breaking in we had a
million people there they tricked a
thousand or so to go in a few hundred
provocateurs broke through the police
similar to what we're seeing uh in
Brazil and so I'm on record there that
day telling people don't go in the
building and trying to stop it when I
say 1776 I'm saying try to take our guns
1776. try to take our Free Speech 1776
it means political Rebellion it means an
Awakening it means saying no
has one of the lessons that you've
learned from this lawsuit with the Sandy
Hook families has one of the lessons
been that actually truth matters have
you learned that do you believe now that
you need to focus on saying things which
are true because consequences can be
very serious
you keep trying to act like it was a big
part of what I've covered or that I made
mistakes on purpose the whole currency I
operate in is the truth and we're
accurate 95 percent of the time I've
made big mistakes
when I make mistakes we absolutely admit
to it I think you've done that yourself
sometime so I'll you know here's the
deal maybe in 10 years you're still
alive I'm alive I'm back on you'll say
will you apologize now I apologize if I
cause any pain I've already done it it
only makes them more rabid and attack
more and misrepresent I went on my show
during the trial and said I love you I
think you're real I'm so sorry for your
child they went on the stand and said I
attacked him that day that's all on
record and and so the problem is the
reason the problem is
a thousand millions of dollars Alex if
they're dead kids the problem is you did
make millions of dollars from their dead
kids it's one of the reasons I did not
it's one of the reasons it's the reason
marketing it's the reason I make
millions of dollars off of it's my
number one book it's the reason it's the
reason right the reason Elon Musk has
refused to let you back on Twitter is he
won't let people on who trade off dead
children that's exactly what you did
so Madeleine Albright kills 500 000 says
question some ass shooting I get it I'm
the worst guy in the world I didn't say
that dying corporate I didn't say that
Alex Jones is bad but here's the thing
infowars.com lives people can come to my
show every day 11 A.M Central and they
can hear what I'm actually saying peers
versus what you're trying to put in my
mouth I see all I'm putting into your
mouth are things that have come out of
your mouth
no you don't have footage of me saying
go harass them at their houses
you don't have any of that you know
utterly contemptible and we both get our
first amendment and I'm glad you had to
move back to England to live under your
Islamic takeover and when they're
arrested
don't be a liar I don't know nothing's
really changed other than in the last 10
years or so he carried on exploiting
particularly the families of Sandy Hook
from massive personal financial gain he
systematically tells conspiracy theories
such I know he knows I'm not true and he
does it because it makes him tons of
money and he's got away with it until
now but now they called his bluff they
sued him and the families won 1.5
billion dollars and he may not have that
but we'll have to give a lot of money to
them
and that's what Alex Jones is about he's
a guy who's conspiracy theories to make
money and doesn't care about the
consequences and finally caught up with
them